mcDonald's have you heard it's not good
for you it really is not this one is big
and I'm completely shocked by this story
because everyone's heard about the pink
slime with McDonald and we're gonna get
into that in just a second but just this
past week McDonald's finally announced
that not that they're changing their
burger recipe for the first time because
Jamie Oliver celebrity chef has been
exposing them for doing this horrific
horrific process with their meat where
they take the awful scraps that's left
after you've taken everything good off
the cow and then you spray it with
ammonia and there are some horrific
videos about this but we're just gonna
show you a slightly cleaner one because
I would be sold at the cheapest for the
dogs okay so you guys are on YouTube
right now I don't want you to click away
but you can check out some other videos
that are much more graphic than that but
basically they're taking stuff that is
not fit for human consumption they are
spraying it with a chemical that can do
all kinds of horrific things to you then
they're pumping it full of all kinds of
other stuff and food dye all this we all
know all this stuff and now they're
finally changing their recipe because of
Jamie yet the media completely just did
not pick this up which i think is quite
bizarre so my first question is are we
just destined to eat this crap no matter
what because I almost didn't do this
story because I think everyone knows how
bad McDonald's is and even if you show
them that crap and spraying it with
chemicals and that you're getting the
worst cuts of people are still gonna go
do we just want to destroy ourself I
can't even believe that people were
referring to the original burger as a
recipe it's more formula than anything
else I mean it's the most disgusting
thing I've ever seen
so I'm super psyched I think that what
Jamie has done and has been doing for a
long time is awesome and this is sort of
like I mean I think that he should
consider it a crowning achievement you
know I mean that ammonia stuff is so
gross it's I mean it's really they are
killing disinfect the meat it is there
to disinfect to me you know get rid of
e.coli things like that but I have to
imagine it's also stripping it aboard
ever minor nutrients might be left in
the meat is there anything I feel like
you've got something here you're ready
you know coming from a scientific
perspective I think that first and
foremost I understand the gut reaction
and and I'm not saying that I disagree
with it because I don't want to eat that
I for sure don't want to eat that so I'm
gonna come out and say that right now
but I would like to see the science
about whether or not the ammonia is
harmful to individuals about whether or
not the ammonia is rinsed away whatever
I think that in this particular case the
reason they do it now they're using
horrific allele Oh quality beef yeah but
that's how you get a hamburger for like
80 cents right so so the issue is yes
they have to ensure that their customers
don't get sick when they eat this now
we're talking about sick in the short
term from infection we're not talking
about aggregate sickness from eating
low-quality food that's nutritionally
barren and you know not getting the
right calories so I think that this is
less an issue about McDonald's and the
profit motive and corporate America and
bulwa and it's more an issue of a
poverty in this country I think the real
issue here is that people who live in
very very low-income neighborhoods don't
have access to healthy clean food and
they're left with only you know a
handful of options which is eating
basically McDonald's dog food on a bun
and yeah I think it's easy for us in
like the [ __ ] top 5% or whatever to
sit around and say like oh you know we
Angelenos would never want to sit around
and there's you know there's hardly any
even fast-food restaurants in Los
Angeles we're very lucky in that respect
but go to certain neighborhoods even
here go to South Central go to Compton
and see what kinds of food choices
people have available to them that's the
problem and that's what we should be
trying to solve I mean I you know I
somewhat agree but I also think that
like where there's a supermarket um
there are healthy options and it's just
it's a matter of Education I actually
I've been hanging out recently with um
Adrian Grenier who has a company called
shift and he actually just released a
new app called food tripping which helps
anybody anywhere in the world find local
organic sustainable healthy food options
no matter where you are but I would I
would venture to guess that the
number of little pins on this app are
significantly higher in rich
neighborhoods right I also think that
when you're talking about a single
mother who's working three jobs and
doesn't have time to go to the
supermarket and buy fresh ingredients
and go home and cook a nice meal for her
family you know she has five minutes to
figure out how to feed her family on a
budget of like three dollars a person
what do you do but get a big bucket of
chicken from KFC I mean the whole system
in this country is I don't want to say
design because that makes it sound like
there's some sort of vast conspiracy but
over time has been has been manipulated
in such a way to keep impoverished
people in a position where they can't
grow out of that poverty and I think a
big part of doing that is being able to
eat well and then being able to think
clearly when you go to school when you
go to work I mean it's so there's such a
link there and then those poor people of
course have either no health care or
worse health care and they're getting
sicker and then they're you know getting
less medical help or no medical help
sometimes some people don't even realize
that like fruit juice is unhealthy you
know and stuff like that and these are
all kind of correlating variables when
you go to low-income areas that's the
sad thing is that the the school systems
are bad the individuals don't have you
know appropriate education available to
them they don't have proper nutrition
available to them and it's just you know
a kind of spiraling problem we have all
known about this pink slime thing and
we've because they just announced that
they switch the recipe but apparently
they did it a few months ago but we've
all known about this and I'm sure that
well I can't swear that we're all gonna
go back to McDonald's but at some point
you might be somewhere on the road and
have to stop somewhere so we know like
even now we were talking about this
earlier but in and out burger here in
California you know it's not cows eating
other cows and all that but it's cheap
but it's just as cheap as McDonald's and
yet for some reason people still go to
McDonald's so I don't know that it's
always about the choices people are
people want to destroy themselves in a
weird way I think yeah I mean I think
it's where we're educated enough in Los
Angeles to know that in and out is
relatively natural in comparison to
McDonald's and that's why a lot of
people choose in and out and even when
you're at the in-n-out drive-through you
can then make the choice whether or not
you're going to have your burger protein
style or with the white
bleached and rich flour by the way wait
I want to show you guys a picture of the
pink slime in case you haven't seen the
pink slime I mean think about that
really just try to get that in your
brain and go 13 percent of my mcdonalds
burger until they just changed this
recipe or formula as you aptly called it
is that yeah I mean I can't I honestly
can't remember the last time that I ate
at McDonald's and I think that there are
some other great things about in and out
you know can't sing their praises enough
and I know that they have like Bible
verses on their bags or whatever weird
of annoying I know it's it's annoy but
um but they they just can't win it you
finally find a burger you're finally
like their worker treatment they're too
you know it's not just about
higher-quality food they you know offer
their their employees full benefits they
offer them the starting wage is higher
than the statewide minimum wage they
even have great programs for their
workers like they can leave their
uniforms at work and they'll be
laundered for them so they don't have to
take that fast-food smell home with them
so they're not kind of walking around
yeah I mean it's a really I think kind
of forward-looking company and so yes I
guess I kind of do retract my earlier
statement about about this isn't really
about corporate America and about profit
motive and things like that because it
would be interesting to kind of compare
the business model of McDonald's in and
out again we're talking though about a
multinational corporation versus
something that's kind of just only on
the west coast now know what you know
you're having a good conversation when
one of the panelists retracts and
earlier that means something was
happening here that we were actually
having a conversation